hey guys and welcome to another HD
tutorial in this video I'll be just
answering your question I was asked an
earlier book in a comment on how do i
get the camstudio to actually follow my
mouse along the screen as I'm moving
along and talking and answering your
questions and such so this is how I get
it actually to follow my mouse it's a
feature built in the camp studio called
autopen so in order to have autopen
you're not actually recording a full
screen i'm recording a fixed region of
the screen which happens to have these
dimensions that you see here 640 x 360
so i have the box check that says drag
corners to pan which means when my
cursor goes outside the corners of the
video or close to the edge it
automatically adjusts the position of
the video so when i go to options i'll
make sure that any autopen button is
checked if it isn't then my mouse will
just go off the screen and will not move
and capture my drag us off you wouldn't
see it so I go to options and enable
auto pen it will always follow my mouse
around the screen so this has been
another issue tutorial thanks for
watching and subscribe peace